hi my name is Christopher moonlight and
I am the producer writer and director of
the quantum terror it's kind of a sci-fi
horror movie which I'm talking to you
from the set of and I want to talk to
you a bit about how we wanted to kind of
achieve the look of this film and what
camera we use what lenses we use not
very extravagant actually we're shooting
on a old Canon 7d crop sensor camera in
a world of Red Dragons and Blackmagic
Cinema cameras been even the c100 and
the c300
it's not a filmmakers ideal choice but
one of the things that I really loved
about this camera was kind of the 7d was
where my knowledge of filmmaking grew
from in terms of the camera standpoint I
remember when the 7d came out and it was
kind of all the rage this cropped sensor
DSLR camera that was kind of I guess the
videographers equivalent of a 16
millimeter camera I really loved kind of
the old sci-fi and horror movies of the
70s the 80s but you know is this is the
days of kind of grainy or grittier
horror movies and sci-fi movies and the
70s actually a pretty grainy gritty
camera really what it comes down to is
who's behind the camera I have a great
cinematographer Anthony Gutierrez who
you will actually hear from in this
video but you know it's it's like if you
were to hand Jimi Hendrix $100
you know thrift shop guitar that guy is
still gonna shred on it whereas you know
you hand a really beautiful expensive
you know hundred thousand dollar guitar
to my four-year-old and your
gonna get noise so we really wanted to
approach this movie with this camera as
cinematographers with an artist's eye so
it really looked at movies like James
cameras aliens where he was doing all
sorts of camera tricks with film speed
trained camera upside down reversing the
footage to make the world that he was
building looked bigger and more
impressive than what he actually had on
set you know maybe it's not such a bad
thing that I don't have an ultra-high
definition 4k or Camera Raw style camera
that is going to see all the nuances of
everything that we're doing so we can
focus on telling this story I'm a big
fan of these sci-fi and horror genre
films so I really have a feel for what
makes them so compelling that both in
terms of the script and how the camera
moves and looks at the characters to
help enhance that story and bring a new
dimension to it I did a lot of
storyboarding after analysing some of my
favorite films aliens The Exorcist
Silence of the Lambs
is a big one for me because what lens
you use for what moment what angle you
shoot from if the camera is moving if
it's not moving all of these things
matter so let's let's talk a little bit
about the lenses because I think they're
very important part of the story ciao so
see what I've got here I have the Canon
50 millimeter lens you'll hear people
talk about these a lot the 50 millimeter
looks like this this is a shallow depth
of field camera the wider you open up
the lens or bring the f-stop down the
shallower depth of field you have
but you're gonna let him more light so
you have to compensate by adjusting your
shutter speed and your ISO but this is a
very cool lens if you want to get in on
someone's face very intensely next up I
have my Canon ultrasonic 28 millimeter
prime lens this is also a really good
lens it's got a really nice stabilizer
on it I'm very pleased with a stabilizer
on this lens which can be very important
if you don't have your awesome Steadicam
operator on any particular day of
shooting and that looks like this this
is the 28 millimeter lens and what it
looks like as you can tell it's also a
wide lens is it kind of is giving you
what you saw from my kit lens but better
quality it has a nice f-stop
it's a 2.8 f-stop wide open so I kind of
I used this as a kind of a medium wide
range lens but I can also get very close
on subjects with it even closer than I
can with a 50 millimeter or my 11 to 16
which just makes people look very
distorted so this is a very good running
gun lens for me and then I have my
Tokina this is a 11 to 16 millimeter
lens I really like this lens because it
goes to F 2.8 you shoot nice and wide on
this which can make your your subjects
look crazy or it can make nice wide
shots in your enclosed set but I'm also
using this for shooting miniatures
there's a lot of miniatures on my film
that are built to look exactly like the
tunnels that you see around me that's
because
maybe a giant monster coming down a
tunnel or there may be a massive flood
of water coming down a Tuttle all things
that I cannot do on my budget so we
build miniature tunnels if you shoot
them with a long lens with a shallow
depth of field you're only gonna succeed
in making your miniatures look more
miniature so if you shoot them with a
nice wide lens and deep depth of field
you can fool your audience with the
proper lighting and color grading into
feeling like they are still in actual
size tunnels though they won't be the
wiser you can keep going with your story
and that looks like this is what my 11
to 16 millimeter lens looks like you see
it's very wide I can get a lot of my set
and the camera is only about that far
from me I could touch the lens if I just
reached a little bit further this is at
its widest and if I just kind of there
we go that's when it zooms into 16
millimeters and you can see it's still
I've still got a lot of range but this
has been a very handy lens for filming
the tunnel sequences if I want to get a
really wide and tense shot or even get
close on an actor who's supposed to be
suffering from some sort of madness or
mania it's got some drawbacks it's a
little grainy err it's also got some
vignette to it and it's maybe doesn't
handle darkness quite as well as it's
going to be extremely handy in shooting
our miniatures and making those look
believable all of these lenses have
different functions but they can be made
to operate outside of those fun
Auctions just as well where most people
would tell you a 50 millimeter lens is
going to be for portraits and the wide
lens is going to be for you know that
prairie or desert exterior Ridley
Scott's gonna get like an 85 millimeter
lens and he's gonna shoot a wide shot
with it you know play around with them
all these lenses can be used handle all
ranges of subject I bought my lenses
because of the nature of my film and the
budget and the availability of the cast
and crew it behoove me to own the lenses
so you know these are not cinema lenses
that I have these are photographer
lenses which are very nice so they ran
me around four to six hundred dollars
each but it was very much worth it for
me to own these lenses they're mine
forever I don't have to worry about
returning them by a certain date and I
can go back and reshoot I can spend time
shooting b-roll on my own you know that
you have so much money for your film and
how much of it are you gonna spend on
equipment and how much are you going to
spend on what you put in front of the
camera I generally find that people will
fall so in love with gear that they
don't have enough left over to put
something very interesting in front of
the camera and therefore you have a
substandard film I actually talked to
Harbinger down director Alec Gillis and
asked him if he had any recommendations
for me he referred me to his
cinematographer Benjamin brown who said
you know what this is your first camera
you're learning how to use it a 7d is a
perfectly viable camera to shoot a
little independent feature on there's
nothing wrong with it and you know it
could add to that
down and dirty gritty
look of an 80s Early 90s horror movie
that you want to achieve the 70
obviously has a lot of weaknesses in
comparison to other cameras today but
those weaknesses are all things that I
can deal with the crop sensor is not
going to allow me to have as much
coverage out of my lens as I could with
a full sensor camera I don't have the
advantage of Camera Raw or 4k overall it
is a very strong camera it's done very
well in low light it can give you a
cinematic feel if you shoot with it
correctly
I love how run-and-gun it is usually the
reason to be using these high definition
cameras you have advantages of being
able to punch in on your footage without
losing quality or if you're doing effect
shots that involve green-screen they
give you a little more leeway with the
color which I would love to have but
they're not problems that are unworkable
for me with the 7d well I think with the
ever-evolving
market for cameras you're never done
researching them so what I really chose
to do was research how the shots I love
and other movies were achieved and spend
a lot of time really understanding what
makes for beautiful shot i sat down with
storyboards breaking down the scripts
creating concept art so that when
everyone got to the set on the day to
shoot we all understood what that image
was gonna be and how we were going to
achieve it and that image was going to
be beautiful whether we shot it through
a 70 or you know red cam but if I had a
red cam and I wasn't thinking about what
was going to be in front of that cam
and how I was going to present it it
wouldn't matter how good the quality my
camera was I'm very pleased with how
this movie is turning out we're still
shooting but I am definitely getting the
look I want out of this camera you know
it's all coming together and there's
been plenty of times where we've been
shooting and I've been looking at the
monitor and you know it just smiled
myself and go yeah this looks like a
real movie so you know again you may be
looking at a big expensive camera that
might be out of your range and who knows
you know in the near future the prices
may come down on those or something new
might come out rendering your decision
obsolete
you know forget about you know what
Hollywood's doing Hollywood's got
hundreds of millions of dollars money
doesn't tell a story money gives you
resources to tell a story but you are
completely capable of telling a story
with a camera and a microphone and a
little bit of set dressing and you know
whether it be some friends or some
up-and-coming professionals that are
willing to work on very low budget like
on my film you can do this
hmm achieving well it wasn't so much my
vision it was the visions that candy
came from
Christopher's concept movie posters and
pictures that he had been posting about
the quantum terror so that sort of
invoked a vision and me what he was
trying to accomplish in camera so that
that was my goal was to try to match
what he was doing conceptually and it's
a completely different look it's you
know sci-fi it's an alternate reality
it's a mind point of view from someone
there's a lot of different things that
go into that psychologically and
when you're jumping through quantum
physics which is kind of cool it's
something that I had not done before
plus the y'all all the practical effects
and miniatures that are involved with it
and trying to make them look as
realistic as possible as we can with the
restrictions that we have which were you
know budget sets things like that so you
know there's a lot of movies in the
future that I'm hoping to do really soon
and this is like an intricate part of
the stuff that I want to do so
understanding his vision and
accomplishing it as as much as possible
is like the first step to doing what I
want to do also again it was trying to
achieve this look and research and it
came from you know looking at a lot of
his artwork which is really really weird
stuff it's very cool so looking at a lot
of that stuff and then realizing you
know we have you know our zeiss 85
millimeter width you know 1.4 we got a
Tokina
we got some 50 millimeters that are
really nice lenses that give these great
depth of fields and you know we're
limited with the lighting that we have
you know it's just a couple of soft
boxes today I was lucky I got some
quino's maybe a 1k so you might be able
to incorporate them so with you know
it's just taking really what we have
applying it as best as we can in camera
to get that vision and then from that
point on its all Christopher fix and
everything I did wrong and post it's
probably not wouldn't have been camera
at my camera of choice but because we're
shooting over an extended period of time
on weekends you know I'm from Dallas
everyone else is from Houston Austin
area so it's like every couple of weeks
we get or every few once a month every
weekend you know we get together to
shoot this so renting a camera such as a
c300 maybe a red or something like that
is
just out of budget so you know he owned
a 70 it was a camera that he had I had
some good lenses capturing really good
audio and then the rest is all you know
done in post so that was what we had in
our hands to accomplish that look and
we're just trying to make the best of it
as as we can especially with the
miniatures very eager to try to make
miniatures and forced perspective with
lenses and can't and the lenses that we
have I'm really eager to try and see how
that's going to turn out I think yeah
aside from you know Christopher's
storyboards in his artwork I didn't I'm
not one to really consult another DP or
another filmmaker about how they achieve
the look just most mostly because I'm
not intimate looking you intimate enough
to know other filmmakers like that to
say hey how did you accomplish that look
I think clearly if there's something
that I'm unable to do in camera then I
would probably be better off as a DP
hiring a camera operator who knew how to
do that I'm not afraid to say it but you
know there's a lot of stuff I don't know
how to do in camera but I quickly figure
it out and make it work and you know
research is you know just an
accumulation of what I've done over the
last 25 years strengths are Chris owns
it so that keeps cost down it's small
its compact the sets that he's built
inside his garage are really small and
compact so it's it's perfect for that
some of the drawbacks is you know it's
not a cinema camera having to balance
you know a DSLR on a Steadicam you know
I have to add extra way things like that
but I mean it does the trick for the
budget that we have and you know how
we're doing things here
it's definitely
an independent film but you know it
works and if it works don't complain
my my personal lens package I have with
me is I have some zeiss crimes I have an
85 a 50 and a 25 most of the camera
operators I know that are shoot with's
have a 50 millimeter of their own or
some stock lens my Zeiss lenses I really
got lucky I bought a filmmaker package
from a big BH and although I hate saying
their name
I bought a film package from them that
included these lenses so I got really
lucky because they were inexpensive and
you know if you were to go out and buy
them separately it would add up to quite
a bit of money but these are really good
lens is really nice lenses for
filmmaking so add it to any DSLR add it
to a C 100 C 300 add it to any Sony
camera or any Panasonic camera and it
changes it adds more of a film look to
it
which is a little bit closer to maybe
like an Alexa or something Blackmagic
you know adding its own warmth and that
and that sort of takes it a step up from
stock DSLR lenses